many many many plays i've done a lot
and so i've always been that funny guy
yeah and you know even in basketball
even when i was in college i was so
funny that the coach didn't take me
seriously
all the players were i was so funny so
comedy was always something you know
that i you know was always good at you
know and i just make people laugh that's
what it was it was just natural for you
and then the show came about and here we
go and the show what was it like being a
part of such an iconic time and era and
tv the 90s it was the best time it was
the best time
it was the best time it was you know you
you don't worry about it you don't trip
off until you look back at it you know i
didn't know what i was doing i had never
been on a tv set i had never been on the
chat i never did acting i had never you
know even thought about this so it was
my wildest dreams and and it's still
it's still
we were thinking about doing a reboot
really yeah we just saw i just saw holly
she did her star
and i saw raven we all got together for
the first time we
said should we come back we said yeah
absolutely so we may see a reboot of mr
cooper you know would you guys like to
see that yeah you got to see do you guys
want me married am i not married
can i play your what daughter you can
play my daughter yes you can
yes we got it we got it all right now
your dreams are still continuing to
blossom here because you once said
i want to be on the road
playing in vegas when i'm 50. yes right
this is the greatest place in the world
to play here i am july 22nd it's a dream
come true to be on the freeway and to
look up and see i stopped i i stopped in
the freeway i stopped i stopped and got
out people's honking hold on hey i'm
gonna be here
tomorrow
now what can people expect in your show
tomorrow the funniest comedy in the
world i'm talking about a little bit of
everything no matter what it is i'm
talking about everything um ladies we
talk about ladies okay you cannot lie to
a woman women women no women turn to
investigators they know oh yeah they
take you to court you know so
yeah they're ready i know you got a lot
of experience yes yes over the years i
have so much so come see it it's a good
show it's funny it's awesome well thank
you so much for being here we are
honored to hang with you